now Emilia box you have hot-footed it
from a slap you're making Silent Witness
at the moment yes this is gonna be
serious as a 22 fairies 22 22 I mean are
you basically a forensic expert now
could you do an autopsy no the shameful
thing is is that all the years I've done
this is my 14th year I probably could be
a pathologist by now but we were
laughing today at some of the things
that we had to say over the years and
and some of them are just funny words
that you have to say but with a very
serious face like I'm sorry but he's
died of schistosomiasis and then I've
had one absolutely death sentence which
I have to really think about remembering
this it was a high binding affinity with
alpha-2 adrenergic and m1 muscarinic
receptors some people going I don't mean
to quibble I literally I had a sleepless
night about that sentence and now it is
seared upon my brain and has been for
many years and you've talked about how
difficult it is for the extras playing
corpses on the slabs cuz they fall
asleep and get erections and things but
I'm so annoyed this didn't happen
because Johnny you were newly a corpse
in Silent Witness weren't you yeah
nearly nearly I was an auction and they
actually optioned off the opportunity to
play a corpse in Silent Witness
that's a brilliant brilliant auction
Rhys
isn't it yeah you don't want something
signed I want to be dead before my time
the price check going off and there was
a guy and he was he was he on quite a
bit of land and he started giving me
dirty looks and he going look he should
be really funny if you didn't know I'd
be brilliant
I mean before we work together yes but I
just wanted you to come in and have one
of those words we go he's obviously died
of schistosomiasis overeating don't you
know what yeah don't go please yeah
there are always pranks going on no cos
corpses are hot because Steven you
haven't played a corpse have you I'm
played a corpse but I've been in place
where you have to be dead oh I did The
Tempest and that a spell is put on
several of us and we lie on the stage
and there are a few older actors in the
and it's a long time you're lying there
and after a heavy week it's tempting to
go to sleep the guy to my right one once
so I was supposed to be under a spell we
suddenly got Oh bollocks
oh my
[Applause]
[Music]
you